oh wait this girl hears me
I'm sandy Wexler can we talk somewhere
I'm a talent manager sandy was not a big
shot even the tiny shot but you never
forgot him any good king of the fake
laugh he's like why are you fake
laughing it's Eddie Murphy please funny
hey they get this kid you've seen at a
party and you think no one even invited
this guy move well I'll get the way
which way you want me to go he dressed
like your grandfather whoa whoa at the
table manners of a horse
Stan you'll get along gadget but you see
crate manager you are a cool wet - are
you four how do you take care everybody
and never worry about yourself that's
what I do an agent is business but a
manager and spammer
I will always do what's best for my
client I was gonna be anybody I'd be her
banana that's why you got me
you can't stop a shooting star I'm
scientists have proven news but we gotta
get to work
yeah why the lights out he's leaning on
the light switch
no I'm not Mike that wasn't me where's
he been
Ramnath top hi bye
stuff for battle but looking like UPS
drivers super cool go brown this job is
my one shot it saved me my marriage what
are you wearing my uniform it's like
you're three beers too intimate
almost